the details of justice ginsburg's
memorial are unique
but her family's grief is recognized by
far too many americans
who have lost loved ones to the
coronavirus the house of representatives
held a moment of silence yesterday to
acknowledge
that painful milestone more than 200 000
people in the u.s
who have died from covet 19. hundreds
more
die every day still an alarming rate of
loss
our lead national correspondent david
begno joins us david
you've witnessed both heartbreak and
resolve
we have anthony you know it wasn't that
long ago when we first heard dr burks
and dr fauci say
there was the possibility and the
potential that we could reach 200 000
deaths in this country
and collectively we were shocked now
seven months into this pandemic
here we are we don't wish this on anyone
natalie and maureen fagan lost their
sister adeline to complications from
coronavirus on
saturday dr fagan who had a history of
asthma
was in her second year of residency as
an ob gyn in houston texas
she had helped to treat coronavirus
patients in the er
and she died after spending two months
in the hospital
she wanted to wake up every day do what
she loved
which is delivering babies be
compassionate
help women help children kimura lynum
died on july 17th
she was just nine years old and had no
underlying health conditions
jermaine stevens dreamed of playing
professional football like his father
the 20 year old died due to coronavirus
complications
earlier this month my son was so full of
life
and had so many plans and so much life
to live and to have that dream deterred
by covid is devastating the reality is
the pandemic is far from over experts
say
28 states report increases in new cases
from one week ago
and cases are rising at rates not seen
in two months
here's former fda commissioner dr scott
gottlieb's fear
as we move in the fall the concern is
that as we
get a little bit more complacent because
we are exhausted as a population from
what we've been going through we head
back to school and college
people try to go back to work against
the backdrop of the fall in the winter
when people are heading indoors
because the weather's cooling that's a
real setup for risk the longer the
pandemic
the more people are at risk from the
elderly to frontline workers
like doctors carlos and jorge vallejo
father and son from south florida
who were both hospitalized with
coronavirus on father's day
they died just weeks apart miss virginia
smith died of coronavirus
at the age of 90. she was a grandmother
to 12 and a great-grandmother to 10.
she was also a devout catholic who
attended mass every day
for nearly 40 years caroline is her
daughter
i think it's really difficult to
understand
what the elderly patients in care
facilities are going through how lonely
they are
and then in their time of greatest need
they're left alone
here are some of the statistics people
55 and older account for 90 percent of
coronavirus deaths
black americans are twice as likely to
die
gail this week we were talking to one of
the leading infectious disease experts
in the country who told my producer and
i something we were shocked to hear
he said i believe that down the road we
will look back and say
if only if only we had just stayed
at 200 000. yes boy
that that leaves us a lot to think about
david i i don't take that 200 000
number lightly at all thank you very
much and it's a reminder it reminds me
of the pieces that you do anthony
that used to do every friday that behind
those numbers yes
are people and 200 000 families and
relatives are mourning the loss
that means millions of people are
literally more but in many cases and the
more we hear
maybe the number didn't have to be that
high that's another thing that's so
painful to acknowledge what we're
looking at with with this virus is a
cause of death that is likely to be in
the top three for the whole year just
behind heart disease and cancer think
about that
yeah yeah no it's a staggering number
and as as david
points out it's not over and we're
seeing in europe a resurgence of
of of cases in the spread of the virus
again so you know
this has got a long way to go yeah we
may say that we're tired of covert but
covet is not done with us
it is still a raging problem we have to
take this seriously